the jurgen experience did you see the
thing
where uh tucker carlson was playing all
these videos of chris cuomo
talking to michael cohen coaching him
on what to say when he interviews him
did not see that oh my god
fox news went cnn just ignored the [ __ ]
out of it they ignored it
and pretended it didn't even happen
right and they didn't address it at all
and fox news played it multiple times
over multiple nights
it is clearly chris cuomo talking to
michael cohen
and he is coaching him on what to say
when he talks to him about the hush
payments crazy but just like i don't
know why he would even
i don't know why they did that well the
cuomo i don't like the idea that one of
them is a governor and the other one's
in the news
but yeah i think maybe that's friends
with michael cohen and he was just
trying to help him out as a friend
like if you were gonna be on let's just
be honest right i'm gonna be honest with
you
yeah if tim dillon was involved in some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and yeah i had an
interview on my podcast right like what
do i say
because you and me alone i would coach
you 100 absolutely i would say this is
what you should say
right yeah especially if i was trying to
help you right yeah i understand that
but if he's friends with that guy yeah i
get it
the problem is he's a broadcaster on
cnn which is the cable news network
was what is it now it's nothing
i mean it's nothing i mean it's absurd
yeah chris cuomo is on there talking
about he's got corona i mean they're
doing like home videos i'm like what is
is
here's another scandal here's another
scandal yeah he pretended to have karana
he is
there's a little bit of the pretending
to leave his basement i'm pretty sure he
had corona
well he said he cured it by chest
exercise i mean i don't buy that
but here's another one there's a picture
of him sitting at his desk
holding a hundred pound dumbbell up in
the air and bodybuilders are calling
[ __ ]
oh interesting i didn't see that also
because of the
angle that he's holding now yeah chris
cuomo
is i'm italian i could say this he's a
guinea
a lot of those guineas are stupid strong
they're they're monkey strings i bet he
is
there a lot of them yeah listen he was a
guy that used to run
a sandwich shop near our house who could
curl his own body weight ten times
and he nobody believed him and this guy
barely lifted weights
and he did it before a wrestling meet he
was like a big time wrestler in newton
south yeah and he wound up losing the
wrestling meet it was like legend in the
town
because his arms were blown out because
he made like a hundred bucks
showing people to curl his body weight
ten times i don't know if
he's [ __ ] serious bro
okay
this is where we get our news no is
there's a photo and he's wearing a
t-shirt this is different
that's real that's a real weight whether
or not that weighs 100 pounds
it might weigh 100 pounds i don't
believe that he has a fake
100 pound weight he's a big person i
think that guy's pretty
large i'm sure he's not i'm sure the
weight isn't fake
that's the picture here's the thing i
i saw these people that are complaining
and saying it's not real
and all this [ __ ] i
listen you can do that that can be done
people who think you can't do that are
crazy he's bigger than me look
he's bigger than me and there's a video
of me on
instagram with a 92 pound kettlebell
and i'm cleaning it and pressing it ten
times over my head right
he's bigger that guy's a lot bigger than
me right he can hold a hundred pounds
over his head and do it like that right
like if i have 100 pound dumbbell in my
chest my
arm right now i could press it he's
bigger than me he could do it
some people are [ __ ] strong yeah i
don't have any problem with doing that
it's when he does look at this
challenge to chris cuomo prove you're
not a liar prove you can actually lift
that weight you're shown with
see this guy just wants attention
because you should know that there's
people that are freaked strong that
could lift that
i like frank's country style throwing a
thousand guys frank's country store
newton
newton uh it was in uh newton it wasn't
newt number false
somewhere in newton massachusetts
newton's center that's such a great
boston story where it's like the guy
loses the team we lose his direction
let's talk about him because we'll buy
subs there because we'd walk there from
school yeah we'd buy subs from frank i
thought the guy he could curl his own
body weight 10 times
he was a tank it's just a legend he was
just a [ __ ] stacked little guinea
right like this five foot seven guy
who's like five foot seven
wide i don't mind people not liking
trump it's weird when they're
like angry like i see chris coleman he's
angry they're angry but isn't that his
job
it shouldn't be but it's entertainment
like tucker carlson's entertainment
he's entertainment on the other side
yeah but anyway tucker carlson's been
ruthless episodes of the joe rogan
experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love